Martin Luther King Jr. dreamed of a world
where people are judged by their character
not by the color of their skin.
And how wonderful would a color-blind world
be?
But what about people who are literally blind?
Do they still judge people based on their
race?
Hey everyone, Julia here for DNews.
Osagie K. Obasogie, a law professor at the
University of California, Hastings, sought
to understand how a person who is blind would
understand the concept of race.
In groundbreaking research published in the
book Blinded By Sight, he conducted over
100 interviews with people of various ages
and backgrounds, all of whom have been blind
since birth.
Obasogie asked the subjects how they define
race, what their first memory of it was, how
their family would respond if they dated or
married outside of their race, among other
things.
And he found some surprising results.
“Blind people understand race just like
everyone else, they understand it visually.
So if you ask a blind person ‘What is race?’
They’re more likely to refer to various
visual cues, such as skin color, facial features,
things of that nature.”
The fact that they use “visual” traits
seems like a surprise.
It’s widely known that blind people do have
a better sense of touch.
But according to a different study published
in the Journal of Neuroscience by researchers
at McMaster University,
it’s not because their brains rewire to
compensate for the lack of sight.
Instead, they show that it’s simple practice
that enhances their sense of touch.
[1]
Some people do take into account other features,
like scent and touch, but only secondarily.
And even though you might assume blind individuals
use voice as a proxy for someone’s race,
Obasogie found that wasn’t the case.
Many of them were distrustful of using voice
because they’ve been wrong so many times
before.
Another interesting finding was
that blind people experience the same racial
prejudice as those with sight.
Many of the respondents pointed to
interactions in their childhood or adolescence
that shaped their views on race.
Those around them, like parents and friends
reinforced social boundaries.
Some had parents that refused to let them
play with people of a different race.
Obasogie also learned that some blind individuals
specifically seek out information about a
person’s race.
And this information makes a profound difference
to them.
Some respondents said it made interaction
easier, that way they wouldn’t say something
stupid in front of someone of a difference
race.
Others used this information as a distinguisher
for dating purposes.
If they were attracted to someone but then
found out they were a different race, they
would change their behavior towards them.
his research suggests that race has less to
do with what we see, and more to do with what
we’re taught.
Society teaches us to mark the physical differences
as significant, and to make certain associations
from those differences.
So yes, even the blind are socialized to see
race, just like we all are.
But by talking to blind people, Obasogie believes
we can get a true understanding of how strong
that socialization practice is.
A big thanks to the University of California’s
Fig. 1 for helping us put this video together.
You can learn a whole lot more from Fig. 1
too - like, whether the secret to a happy
marriage is in your DNA.